and finally i'm happy to announce a film
about one of the truly iconic marvel
families
in fact marvel's first family fantastic
we're working on a feature now and it
will be directed by the director of our
recent spider-man films
john watts we've got a lot in store at
marvel studios
and disney plus is key to the
interconnection and expansion of the mcu
it will be home for both our feature
films and our series for years and years
to come
what's going on everybody it's warren
and we just had an
absolutely insane night with disney's
investors day
there were some massive reveals
including a first look at many of the
shows that we've been waiting for
including the falcon and the winter
soldier
the loki series and the one division
series we got a new trailer for and our
first look
at marbles what if and the official
trailer for that as well
if you haven't checked out my reaction
to them you can but let's talk about
possibly the biggest
news that we got during marvel's
investor day and that is
the confirmation that the fantastic four
are coming in phase five kevin feige
said that they are working
on a feature now this is huge news that
means marvel studios has
probably already cast mr fantastic the
invisible woman
the thing and the human torch they've
probably already casted all of the main
characters for this film
and if he's talking about working on a
feature to possibly show us that means
they are already
filming or they're going to very very
soon so marvel's first family is coming
a lot sooner than we thought they were
going to be coming and with kevin feige
the president of marvel studios
officially confirming that they
are on their way we won't have to wait
much longer and they will come
in marvel's phase five so let me know
what you think about this in the
comments down below how excited
are you for the fantastic four to
finally be entering
the marvel cinematic universe leave your
thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest mcu news
and so you can enter this week's
giveaway which is a mysterio
zombie funko pop i'm picking a winner
tomorrow don't forget to follow me on
twitter for live updates and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
you